okay look I know it takes a bunch of
studios to get these prestige films mate
and you want to make sure everyone gets
credit but 59 seconds of opening logos
is entirely too many seconds of logos
reading also inquisitive reading I'm
watching a movie goddammit I don't need
to be questioned welcome to man this is
jeopardy this is a very specific program
that was super popular in the early
2000s and was originally hosted by Regis
Philbin back when he was alive and it
makes this movie dated as hell oh so
you're the one who calls me up every
single day of my life is special officer
game show host humor it's hard and my
wife is giving me him man this movie
Dutch angles so hard at me as well be an
Aerosmith video I've got a desk full of
murderers rapists extortionist bum
bandits and you
so maybe concentrate more on them and
less on torturing Charles Van Doren
junior here also the original title of
this film was quiz show for sadists what
the heck
no is it close enough yes I'm being told
this is close enough for a roll credits
congratulations also this entire premise
is based on a hunch that this kid can't
know enough to win the show and I
understand there's a whole derogatory
caste system and all that but it's also
a flimsy ass premise Jesus what a
dizzying amount of cuts what the hell
Danny Boyle yeah we're the jaws of the
one god damn the sequence is so shoddy I
briefly thought it was directed by
Richard Donner
okay maybe the security folks are just
trying to scare the kids and run them
off the land but it still doesn't
explain how these children are
outrunning the motherfuckers who are on
motorized scooters now this did the kids
plan this coordinated attack on the
security personnel they were literally
just playing cricket and are currently
being pursued so where did these little
assholes come from this isn't like the
Battle of Endor when you've got time to
plan all these is there seriously one
cop chasing them now what's he planning
to do hearing all eight of these kids
two swift justice by himself okay I'm
probably being too hard on this chase
scene but it's also alive and pissing me
off look how far ahead of that dickhole
they are here there's no way he's
keeping up with them even around the
next turn that's right Looby just made a
scene transition by going straight
through this poor woman's butthole oh
man I thought a movie that murdered the
Oscars and it's only a little over ten
years old would hold up a lot better
than this man who knows all the answers
Oh Oh a good dog they just torturing the
shit out of Jamal though and he didn't
say anything then right is he gonna be
more forthcoming with a light tap on the
head while sitting at the desk are you
ready for the first question for 1,000
of these Wow they've got this recording
cued up to be perfectly correlated to
the script I didn't think an Oscar
contender can have this much poop
related plot ever again
but then the help comes around in a few
years to prove me wrong no no no no no
hell no no no no no to all of this
instead 40 extra sins what a weird scene
and a ridiculous reason for Jamal to
know the answer to the first question
why is on a table visiting the slum
anyway nobody but Jamal can't even get
near him and he arrives by helicopter to
help and actually maybe a good answer
for this in the previous script version
or the book but you know what we say
around here about the books so the
police are keeping all these people back
from Amitabh but they allow it so child
through and once he gets through he's
got all this time to ask for the
autograph without any interference and
this afternoon is clearly a saint as he
didn't even question the side of this
poor child
the legend interesting I haven't been to
India but is it common for TV hosts
there to openly antagonize their
contestants I'm not talking about Steve
Harvey giving you the exaggerated side I
for the answer on the feud prem is being
a supreme dick to jamal this whole time
i swear i got at least 82% of this
movies running they may as well a cast
Tom Cruise you know there are a couple
of longest shots of them running away
from the riots but rather than
I'm reminded about the rest of the
sequence that's cut up more than a
fucking Marvel fight scene just one
sixteen thousand Ruby I know this
question led Jamal to think about his
mom so he's understandably upset but the
rest of the times he answers he looks
just as depressed so I'm wondering if
his hearts even really into it the show
is awful by the way I mentioned what an
asshole premise but between that and the
morose motherfucker right here would
anyone dig this would you ever take the
money alive even if this is something
gameshow hosts do on commercial breaks
premise still miked up right there's no
way the producers killed his volume that
quickly as if this movie's not
depressing enough let's cut to the poor
child in the middle of a monsoon
wait that's not sad enough for you okay
bring in the puppies wouldn't she be
more likely to alert security standing
in the middle of a lot hello great child
abduction in the middle of a trash dump
so the movie can get even more
depressing I'm trying to think if I seen
a more obvious villain that's introduced
as a possible good guy
maybe penny wise yeah I think that's
about it holy saline Rose fast in this
organization along with fighting with
Panisse did he also shank the biggest
kid in the camp the first night Jesus
Christ this is so deep of a Dutch angle
it's practically Belgium Chile is on his
Willy was coincidentally the name of my
crossover thrash steam punk band in
college
Hayati ah hey me too
wait are we all talking about the movie
being over because I'm Wade ready for
that moobot style
thank God it'd been like 15 minutes
since the last runnin scene and you know
how much I likes my running
Jesus this score has its moments but
here it sounds like we've wandered into
an episode of castle I guess it's a
trade-off between not screaming your
whereabouts to your pursuers and
motivation to your companion but I think
I'll go with the former convenient
escape train is escape train so the does
guess what alright man at least in the
other flashbacks we've seen how Jamaal
knew the answers but for this one it's
completely overlooked sure he sings the
song for the asshole kidnapper guy but
there's no mention of the name of the
songwriter millionaire montage it's at
this point in the movie that mi eyes
paper planes is playing and I could not
be more shocked that it took so long for
that to happen I could have sworn after
the first time I saw this that the song
played the entire movie kind of like
Paul Westerberg dyslexic heart in
singles no one will be seated during the
goofy train exploits of Jamal and Selene
portion of the movie of course the
somewhat happy section of the movie has
to end somewhat tragically I don't want
you to feel joy for more than oh say
more than 6 consecutive minutes I guess
it must be considering that they're
looking back at where the train tracks
were and if that's the case they should
be either dead or looking directly into
the super steep hill from which they
just roll cool transition I guess they
look like they were still kids before
they fell but the tumble down the hill
aged them several years forward look I
respect the hustle but I'm gonna give
the Taj Mahal security a big old sin for
letting these kids take over the guided
tour more than once
hey I just said the Taj Mahal look at me
[Music]
I almost want this to be a parody of
some dumbass rich white American couple
but the more I think about it the more
this looks like a perfect depiction of
some dumbass rich white American couple
and not even gonna add or subtract us in
here I just wanted to point that out
this reminds me of a book I once read
called under the bleachers it was
written by Seymour butts I'll be here
all week
[Music]
I see Jamal's come down with a classic
Orpheus complex who's done a thousand
rupee note so Jamal can remember the one
time his buddy told him who was on the
$100 bill but he's never looked at a
thousand rupee before that had to have
been more frequently in his possession
right
I know movies trying to say that the
unusual nature of the situation is what
made Jamal remember Benjamin Franklin
but it also presupposes he's got
somewhat of a photographic memory so
this is some bull right here whoa not
only does Jamal's old buddy from the
orphanage from hell immediately know
who's on the American $100 bill he also
immediately recognizes Jamal this is the
amazing kid we should be following right
get him on the show in order to track
down motika Jamal is assisted by the
most helpful prostitutes this side of a
Law & Order episode he thought you could
just walk him and dig my prize away yeah
I had some reservations about that plan
too evil kidnapping child abusing
asshole I would say you'd be excellent
at cinema sins but even we aren't evil
kidnapping child abusing assholes who
invented them all whoa okay even if I
buy the Jamal's experience these answers
before I'm not buying that they're asked
in a perfect sequence to line up with
his life's events also I'm calling bull
on James revolver being an option on a
question worth 2.5 million rupees that's
a three hundred rupee option at best had
anyone behind this film ever seen Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire
and this is all it takes to convince
Javeed some Rando queen with a handgun
shows up to a balcony casino and he's
all this kid totally checks out point is
Salim not been number one sure Jamal
convinced him to come back to Mumbai but
it's not like he gave up his AlphaDog
status to tackle or move he's just
inventing new ways to show us what an
asshole he is and we get it already
you need the exercise go and get me
something to eat yes sir maybe don't
insult the man you're putting in charge
of getting the food especially when you
don't even tell him what you want
no what is he really talking to the film
crew and they left that in why so if
it's currently a little past 8:00 in the
morning in London then it should be
three o'clock in New York and not ten
like the clock show here also it should
be 12 o'clock in Los Angeles and not 9
o'clock as this clock shows these clocks
are the biggest lie this movie
hey it's Indian lerton star
lock big lock been locked big ben is
this scene meant to show us how jamal is
able to Keyser söze a story together
because if so this doesn't inspire any
confidence in his talent cyberstalking
we interrupt this Slumdog Millionaire
movie to bring you a very special
episode of 24 holy man it's been how
many years I know these guys are
brothers at all and there's probably a
magical ability to recognize their
voices in context but this is a
completely random call from working
cellphone service this isn't just
magical this is next-level Harry Potter
raises the dead parrots from the grave
I'm Gulf OD London computer-ji d' lock
kiya-jaye
but tomorrow never say it final answer
seriously did no one watching gameshow
that is the center of this movie's
storyline is there a question no earlier
Salim went into this whole soliloquy
from hearing dudes voice but now he's
got a check you need to go now
take my card hey look at that Mumbai has
actual card-carrying criminals you think
that one already out of my sight egg
enough he's David Mena younger brother
referring to a sibling as that sibling
to the sibling cliche ah sudden
immediately conspicuous Latika seriously
did Jamal know that Salim was coming to
her he's literally risking his and his
brother's life just to see what's up
with javi this works
Baz Luhrmann's William Shakespeare's
Jamal plus Latika shut up the good news
on cricket
hey Latika would definitely be excellent
at cinemasins and we'd be happy to have
her man I haven't seen someone this mad
at a sporting event since Chris through
was wallet at his TV and broke that
month during a Nashville Predators game
you mean Latika was able to evade these
assholes all the way to the train
station but they're just now catching up
Jesus if she'd spent less time sexually
staring she'd be up and running with
Jamal by now you know who's done that
this is very close to a villainous
exposition soon but I guess prims not
supposed to really be a villain right I
don't know I feel like everyone in this
fucking movie is all kinds of evil be
Ricky Ponting or Dean Jack Hobbs oh yes
in addition to having a conveniently
photographic memory Jamal also has a
world-class ability to call out a high
stakes bluff seriously just give this
character actual superpowers at this
point this is a bizarrely possible yep
that's about as high of a praise as I'd
give this movie to just try it
there wouldn't be another chance so now
Salim is a good guy I can't figure out
if this movie is more wishy-washy with
its characters or its plot 40 straight
seconds of hot traffic action Jesus good
thing Salim didn't have his voicemail
set up whether it be no way Latika makes
it back to the phone in time movie
timing am i right the audience and the
staff are just sitting around while the
phone rings for I don't know maybe 3035
minutes of real time all numbers are
approximate you really are on your own
you'll final answer for twenty million
rupees or he could still walk you can
choose to take the money after using a
lifeline which this movie clearly
doesn't understand hey this works hey
man good for Jamal and everything but
this ending to the show is about as
plausible as the jiho sequence happening
in reality considering everyone knows
who Jamal is now and he literally just
became a millionaire I'm calling bull
that he would be able to have a peaceful
moment to himself at the train station
yeah thank God we got a chance to cram
in one last crooked-ass Dutch angle
seriously I'm gonna need a chiropractor
after watching this movie
yes but the Hound of did he get on the
gameshow that question was asked earlier
but never King answered and it seems
like a pretty important question for the
movie to answer Chyna
you're gambling man what say we flip for
it he's a freak he's a fast killer
barfing all of the Park Rangers here at
Alcatraz were at one time guards myself
included my name is John Johnson but
everyone here calls me Vicky will you
please follow me you really connect the
enemy of my enemy is my enemy look tense
dad the key to a happy life is to accept
you are never actually in control
no Iowa
thank you commercial break don't go mate
now
hardcore parkour